Good afternoon, everybody. The magic clock over there says it's time to
start, so we're going to start.
I'm Electra Paskett, and I am thrilled to be the moderator for this
session entitled "Bridging the Gap: Multilevel Strategies to Expand
Access to Clinical Trials."
So
this session focuses on
sites that are participating in the Connecting Populations to Clinical Trials
initiative funded by the National Cancer Institute.
The goal of the initiative is to understand why accrual to clinical trials is
low and to increase referrals and accrual to NCI-sponsored
clinical trials. The initiative is structured with four academic
sites and a coordinating center, as well as
interaction with the National Cancer Institute.
Each site has its own intervention, its own study design,
its own procedures, which you are going to hear about from the four
sites. And then the coordinating center oversees common data
collection,
et cetera.
So I'm going to introduce our speakers to begin with,
and then we will all go in this order and then take
questions at the end. So I'm going to talk about our
site's project, which is called Accrual to Clinical Trials,
and then I will be followed by Dr. Susan Vetter Bramble from
the Moffitt Cancer Center and Research Institute.
Hers is called ACT Wonder Squared S,
which is Advancing Clinical Trials Working Through Outreach Navigation and
Digitally Enabled Referral and Recruitment Strategies.
She will be followed by Dr. Melissa Simon from Northwestern University,
the Support Trial, the ECCOACRN NCI NCORP Community
Oncology Practice Sites Clinical Trial Referral Initiative.
And then Dr. Janice Rapp Krieger will be our last
academic site from the University of Florida, Meet Alex, A
Tailored Intervention to Build Trust and Facilitate Cancer Clinical Trials
Referrals. And then we will hear from our coordinating center, multiple
PI, Dr. Folake Odedina from the Mayo Clinic,
Florida, and her presentation is entitled "Enabling a Cross-Site
Network is
CUS 2 CT Through a Learning Collaborative Data Coordination and
Evaluation."
All right. So I'm going to start with our site at the Ohio State
University, and my colleague in this
as multiple PI is Dr. Cheryl Lee.
So the purpose of our project is to increase referral and accrual of
participants to
prevention and treatment trials at The James and across the state, which is our
catchment area.
We have three specific aims which match three phases.
The first is a baseline assessment of referral and accrual patterns.
The second is to implement a bi-pronged multilevel intervention focused in nine
counties, highlighted there in the blue on the map,
and then evaluate the impact of the intervention on referral and accrual to
clinical trials.
The design is a stepped wedge design, group randomized multilevel
intervention. It includes outreach components, which our community outreach and
engagement team
is working on, directed at community members and community practices, and then
an in-reach component involving patients, providers, the hospital
system at both the referral centers and the OSU Comprehensive
Cancer Center.
So this intervention that we then designed directly
addresses the challenges that are identified in phase one, and I'll talk a little
bit more about that as we go along. Our conceptual model is
first, the model for analysis of population health and health disparities
developed by the Centers for Population Health and Health
Disparities initiative, lovingly called the Warnecke model
after D**k Warnecke. And this basically says the reason we have
disparities in health outcomes is not just because of individuals'
behavior, but multilevels from social conditions and policies all the way
down to biology and genetic pathways.
And then we also use this socioecologic framework called the accrual to clinical
trials framework that we developed, which basically
states that the patient and physician have an interaction if they're talking
about clinical trials, but they're not in isolation.
They all have systems around them and then the community around
them that influences that interaction.
So taking this multilevel approach to referral and enrollment
allows us to intervene then at all of those levels, the patient, the
provider, the system, and the community.
The ACT framework is our socioecological framework, and it highlights the
interrelated levels of that I've talked about, the
patients, the providers, and the health system.
And then screening and key informant data
provide a roadmap to identifying challenges and
facilitators to trial referral and enrollment.
So I'm going to now talk a little bit about some of the results from
phase one,
and specifically from the key informant interviews.
So these are the common challenges to clinical trial accrual that all of the
sites where we went and did key informant interviews reported.
At the patient level, lower health literacy around clinical trials, the
cost of treatment not covered by insurance, as well as the
cost of time off from work, fears that clinical trial may
delay care and uncertainty of trials, transportation issues,
mistrust of the healthcare system, and lack of a referral to a clinical
trial. At the provider level, cost and time to pre-screen and
consent patients,
lack of clinical trial-related knowledge at the provider level and available
clinical trials at the site. At the system level,
limited access to clinical trials, complicated clinical trials,
meaning strict eligibility criteria, IRB
delays in getting the protocol open, outdated paper resources for
trial availability, lack of staff coordinators for recruitment and patient
engagement around clinical
trials.Now, what are then some
facilitators that we heard in these key informant interviews?
At the patient level, educate the patient on all these clinical trial terms,
and talk about the benefits to participating.
At the provider level,
give education books on clinical trials, how to properly
consent patients, incentivize clinical trial accrual,
and emphasize the value associated with supportive care and prevention clinical
trials, greater involvement of the primary care docs, and
attend tumor conferences and boards.
At the system level, maintain electronic resources for trial
availability and details, use EMR prompts, patient
navigators, advertise clinical trials, especially on social
media, identify one point of contact for each clinical trial.
And this is especially relevant to referrals.
If you're calling in from an outside practice, what number do you
call? You call the
293-5000, you're not going to get anybody.
So what's the number to call, especially for your disease?
So at phase two, we want to implement then this multi-level intervention
that then addresses the challenges identified at each
level, patient, provider, hospital, community.
So,
the other thing that we did, in addition to the key informants, was we
looked at referral pathways. All right.
So this is a protocol that we developed called the Accrual Enhancement Protocol.
Now, for how many years have we been focusing on the
reason we don't have people on clinical trials is because
they don't agree. How many years? I've been in this business a long time, and we
always started, "It's the patient's fault."
Then we started with, "Well, it's the provider's fault." Well,
actually, no. Okay. So think about how a person gets
on a clinical trial. So, N.
We did this
audit for every single oncology clinic at
Ohio State. I'm not going to show you the real data, but I'm going to show
you examples of what we found. All right.
So this is a generic model, and
when the patient comes,
they're referred for a trial. So in order to refer for a trial, there has
to be a trial. There has to be a trial for that patient's
disease and stage.
Then if there's a trial, are they eligible?
And you know about the eligibility criteria.
So point A is do you even have a trial for that patient's
disease?
Point B right here is
are they eligible?
And then if they're eligible, which we bring that down here, are they
approached? Are they asked to participate?
And then if they're asked, then the patient part comes
in, which is do they agree to go on? So we have points A,
B, C, and D, and all of these
points are intervention points,
and you can customize it to a clinic and even a
doctor for each of these points.
So,
what we did then is,
as I mentioned, we did an audit for patients
in these clinics and
gave them the data back. So what I want to get to
is the next one, which is the example.
And then the next slide is going to give you specific interventions for
each of these points, A, B, C, and D.
So this is a hypothetical, but not too hypothetical,
data where you have 2,000 patients, and we screened, let's just say
we screened a clinic, 2,000 patients they saw in the last year.
Only 40% of them had a trial
for their disease, and of those,
only 28% were eligible.
And of those, 68% were approached and
62% were consented. So if you looked at the clinic metrics,
5% of the total patients were consented from these 2,000.
If they were referred for a trial, it went up to 8.5, and if they were
eligible, it's 42%. Okay?
So now let's break this down a little bit at each of these
inflection points and see what kind of interventions we can come and do,
customized for that clinic.
So point A, which is there has to be at least one trial
that the patient's eligible for. At least one trial for
their disease.
So you can make a list of clinical trials.
You can have a clinical trial point of contact.
You can have a clinical trial navigator, and you can have clinical trial
concierge access, which is you're referring a patient in,
you can then
get that patient to the right trial.
The other point on this one is you need to know your patient population,
and let's not have too many boutique trials.
And the reason for boutique trials is here, which is
eligibility.
So you can maintain a screening log and look and see
what the eligibility problem is and see why they're
ineligible. And if you're doing investigator-initiated trials, you can make a
difference. If you're in a cooperative group, which many of us are, we get
those eligibility criteria. You can go back to your cooperative group, and you can
talk about eligibility criteria.
Point C. This is when the patient is
approached. You can provide education to all
of the providers and the staff. You can encourage
provider engagement in tumor boards to look at eligible
patients, interaction, and advertisement.
And then for the patient to be consented to the trial,
again, you can provide education on how to talk
to patients, how to consent to themYou can
translate your consent form into the
languages that your patients speak.
You can
try to provide more time in a clinic
visit to consent during the clinic visit.
You can use navigators to explain what a clinical trial is
outside of the clinic visit, and you can
provide education not only to the patient, but to the community,
and do an accrual
campaign.
So what we've learned so far is that collaboration with the clinical trials team is
vital,
and making the effort to obtain accurate screening data is vital to the
effort of referring and enrolling patients to clinical trials.
Because if you didn't look at the data, you would think it's all the
patient's fault,
and in the example I showed you, it wasn't.
And those percentages for ABCD varied by every
clinic.
And if we have time, somebody can ask me which was the best clinic, and I can tell
you. Tailoring interventions allows us to build capacity
in the community and develop an infrastructure.
Again, each clinic, each healthcare system is uniquely different,
and what we're doing allows them to then have tailored interventions.
And we need to work closely with all the stakeholders
to really have the outcome we want and to build
sustainability. So I just want to thank the
research support for this project and also the
multitude of our staff and investigators who are
working on it. So thanks very much.
Can I have the 30 seconds that you've allotted?
I need to come away.
Darn it.
Hi, everybody. Electra already introduced me and
the title of our study, called Act Wonders,
so I'll jump right into it. Over the course of the
12 strict minutes that we have, I'm going to describe our
study design and our target population, talk about our
intervention components across each level, and since this is a methods
workshop, I wanted to highlight our approach to
stakeholder engagement across each of these various levels and
share some level-specific preliminary outcomes and, like Electra,
lessons learned.
So our study design is a multilevel intervention, similar
to Electra's, informed by the socioecological model.
We use what's called a cluster stratified randomized design, and I'll talk
a little bit more about what that means.
Basically,
our clusters were geographic, what we call priority zones.
So these were specific areas within our 23 county catchment
area of Moffitt Cancer Center that had a higher proportion
of populations that typically had lower
participation in therapeutic clinical trials.
We found 14 such zones in our catchment area that were
randomized to intervention or control.
We had external targets for our intervention, including community members and
community physicians in the priority zone, and internal
targets, which included Moffitt-based physicians, clinical research
coordinators, and patients from priority zones.
Our study outcomes are similar to
probably all of ours, which is the percent of patients referred to
Moffitt and the percent enrolled, in our case, in therapeutic clinical
trials from within the priority zones.
We also used the RE-AIM framework for implementation outcomes.
So here's the three aims of our study, and we are
here, which is we have a two-year intervention period that
started in September of 2024. So we're wrapping up our
intervention period in September of 2026,
and that's sort of the initial data that I'll be sharing today.
Electra did a beautiful job of talking about the
socioecological model, and just to put a fine point on why
we all gravitate towards this model is that lack of
participation in clinical trials is complex and it's
multilevel, so it requires a coordinated,
intentional, thoughtful effort across all of these levels to
really make a difference that we see.
So here,
using our socioecological model framework, is our
suite of interventions at the community,
system, provider, and patient level.
And to my point, I'll go through these in a little bit more detail in the next
few slides, but to my point, many studies often have,
let's say, a community advisory board that they use.
But when you're talking about complex, multilevel
interventions, engagement goes beyond that, and they're not
always the usual suspects, let's say, that are the stakeholders you
need to engage. And so I'll emphasize a little bit of that as I go
through each level of intervention.
You'll note we have three provider level interventions.
I'll focus only on the TrialConnect Portal in the interest of time.
So our community
member facing intervention is clinical trials education sessions.
So this is actually based on NCI's clinical trials education module
developed for the National Outreach Network for Community Health
Educators that addresses various aspects of clinical trials
delivered in English or Spanish by four community health educators
trained and hired specifically for this study.
In terms of stakeholder engagement, our CAB was
fundamentally necessary because we were trying to reach a
very broad area... to settings that had the
capacity to be able to help us host these community
events. And so they connected us in many of these areas that we
hadn't really been in with local community organizations.
One point that I really want to make is that over the course of our
intervention period, we had 36
community sessions. But look at how many
contacts it took to get to those 36
sessions. Right? Community work is long
and repetitive and trust building and
engagement. And so it really does take
time. It's not like you just plop yourself into a community
in some random part of the catchment area.
And so I wanted to really call out the work that it takes to get
there. So here you'll see our actual community clinical trials
education sessions. The pictures in the middle just are some from
different sites. Figure three
shows our clinical trial educations.
We were able to have sessions in every priority zone
as we had targeted. So the blue bars show how many sessions that
was, and then the green numbers are the number of participants.
So we had 36 sessions that reached nearly 500
participants to date. We still have a few more months for the intervention.
And as you can see, everything is moving in the right direction of what we hoped.
So everything improved from pre to post
in terms of familiarity, intention to participate in trials, as well
as knowledge. So a nice level specific effect that we're seeing.
Another area that Dr. Paskett really did a nice job
of summarizing are sort of those
variables that are kind of above the physician and
patient that matter when it comes to enrolling folks on
clinical trials. At our institution, we developed a
suite of three digital tools that were designed for Moffitt
physicians as well as trial coordinators to
enhance patient accrual by, one, identifying gaps
in the trial portfolio. We call that the portfolio profiler.
That is, do the trials we have open match the burden of
cancer in our catchment area? If we have no trial for
population X that has a higher proportion of liver cancer, then how
would we expect that we're going to see more individuals from that particular
background? The second was mentioned earlier
about eligibility criteria. So one
sort of rate limiting step is that certain racial ethnic
minority groups may have a different prevalence of
comorbidities or lab values that tend to exclude them
from trial participation. We created a digital tool that
allowed physicians designing IITs to look at what does
slight change with safety in mind to eligibility
criteria open up in terms of the potential cohort of Moffitt
patients that would be eligible for the trial.
And then third, we developed a recruitment dashboard based on
sociodemographic characteristics so folks could see how we were
doing. All of this was made available on our
internal website that could be accessed by any Moffitt team
member. I mentioned stakeholder engagement, so obviously the
target users were really important.
What did they want in terms of functionality?
We collaborated with our informatics team, health data
services, people I had never heard of until this particular
project, and of course, our research team.
And we had a phenomenal clinical trials office
that said, "How do we get these resources into
the typical workflow of our trial coordinators and
physicians?" And we were able to embed links to these tools in our
trial feasibility form and our IIT protocol development
template to enhance use. We had a lot of promotional efforts.
So you can see our most popular tools, by number of users,
was our portfolio profiler and our recruitment dashboard.
But in terms of number of visits, it was our eligibility criteria
calculator. I'm very happy to see
that a high proportion of people came back to the tools.
So 80%, once we got them using a tool,
came back. And here is the breakdown of the groups
that were actually using these tools. So again, this data is in progress.
Hopefully, we'll see even more as the study continues.
So this is my sad slide. This is called
our TrialConnect portal. So this was our intervention that was geared
toward community physicians. And we did the
same type of user-centered design. We had a lot of enthusiasm.
We developed a digital platform that allowed community
physicians to search open trials at Moffitt, to submit
referrals, and communicate with Moffitt staff.
And
we
promoted this with our marketing team to physicians in the
priority zone. So lots of user-centered design, same
collaborations with those teams.
In addition, now our strategic marketing team was involved because they're
used to reaching out to referring providers for a variety of
resources at Moffitt. So you can see we had a
gigantic mailing campaign, physical mailing, email campaign,
flyer distribution. But here's why it's a sad slide.
We had very few external physicians who
actually availed themselves to the TrialConnect
portal. So the study is in progress. We'll rethink.
But an interesting finding is that our internal physicians
and trial coordinators said, "This is fantastic.
We love being able to search all the eligible trials." And so maybe that's a
potential direction, but it doesn't solve the referring community provider
issue.We also provided for
patients at Moffitt, specifically from the priority zones,
access to a tool we call Choices DA.
This is a web-based decision support tool to
encourage folks to think about therapeutic clinical trials that was developed
by an investigator at Moffitt. You can see there's a poster about this, so
please check it out. The beauty was, this was an automated
tool. Once we got all the logistics worked out, every
patient from the priority zone automatically got a link
to this in their patient portal and via email, as well as
reminder and emails or texts.
We collaborated with our patient and family advisory council, as
well as senior IT staff, because this wasn't just for
the study in one sense. We integrated into what
Moffitt patients see every day. So in that way, it kind of
became a low-intensity intervention, right?
Something we didn't have to actively have our coordinators doing.
So in that case, we had 25% usage, which isn't
bad when you think about that we really had to do nothing, sort of
after the initial programming. And here's some examples of the viewing
patterns in terms of review, returning users,
average page views, et cetera. Importantly, compared to
all who were eligible to view the tool, we saw not too much
difference. We saw that the tool was more likely to be used by individuals
who identified as white and Hispanic, and slightly less likely
for those who identified as Asian or unknown in those
categories. But not a huge difference.
And importantly, we had a voluntary end-user survey,
which allowed us to assess how did people
like the tool, sort of on a scale of zero to 100, and you can see
that overall, these metrics are positive.
So in terms of lessons learned, continuous stakeholder
engagement is essential for adaptation, dissemination,
sustainability. Multi-level interventions require
specific tailoring and routine collection of both process
and outcome metrics.
Even though this is a research study, integrating into routine clinical
workflow made all the difference in terms
of having this present and prevalent at Moffitt.
And
multi-level interventions are complicated, but they
can be done with the right level of stakeholder engagement.
Thank you.
All right. It's my turn.
There we go. Okay. So,
I
am the MPI with Dr. Elise Park, who couldn't be here today, and she
apologized for not being here. But she is from MGH, and so we have
a team that's at Northwestern and at MGH Dana-Farber.
But we've been working with ECOG-ACRIN for a long time, and we thought this
was an opportunity to create a study
looking at the structure, the infrastructure, right?
NCI NCOR is a very important part of the NCI
clinical trials. And so why not try to
tackle community oncology practice sites and trial
referral, since clinical trial referral is part of
standard of care for oncology patients.
So our aims were to conduct
a preliminary assessment, because again, working across multiple
sites across the country that were not in either of
our own backyards, neither MGH's backyard nor
Lurie Cancer Center, Northwestern's backyard.
It was really important to do the first aim.
And then the second aim was to conduct a hybrid type one cluster
randomized rollout effectiveness implementation trial,
with a sample size of about 500 Black and Hispanic patients
diagnosed with cancer to evaluate the effectiveness of this intervention to improve
referral and accrual, but referral is
the primary outcome, and then to evaluate. All right.
So again, here's our sites. We have seven NCOR
sites that have multiple sub-sites.
Aurora, Baptist, Carle, Georgia, Geisinger, Montefiore, and
SCOR.
And they're in very
unique spots on the east half of the
country.
So our inclusion/exclusion criteria,
again, multilevel is really important, but it's not just
that it's complex to get improvement in
clinical trial enrollment. It's complex to accrue.
I'm a physician. I'm a OBGYN. I practice.
And just accruing, or I'm sorry, referring
patients requires multiple levels.
And so each of those levels, as an implementation health equity
scientist, each of those levels have barriers and
challenges. And so you need to look at under the hood of
the car for each of those parts of
referral that's important. And thus, that's why we designed the trial that
we did. English-speaking proficiency for providers, English or
Spanish-speaking proficiency for participants,
anyone 18 and older,
and anyone who's eligible to participate in an NCI-supported clinical
trial. It wasn't that there was necessarily a trial open for the participant right
at the time
of entry, and that was a really important part.
Our phase one was completed. We had provider surveys, patient
surveys, and qualitative interviews.
What we found was very similar to what you're hearing on this
panel.
Only about 40% from a patient perspective,
said that they discussed clinical trials with doctors at
all.Only about 20% said they'd been referred to a cancer
clinical trial. This is across all sites, and only 11%
participated in a clinical trial.
From the provider perspective, though, there seems to be a little disconnect.
About 90% said they referred racial and ethnic
minority patients to cancer trials.
So again, there is this disconnect,
and a perception. It could be perception.
Patient interview themes, knowledge of clinical trials.
Some participants had absolutely no prior knowledge, and again, this is
standard of care.
Benefits of clinical trials, they felt that they were helping others and
helping to participate in new treatment discoveries and finding a cure.
And they were willing to discuss, and this is something I find a lot
over the last 20 years of doing work in this space.
People assume that folks of color don't want to
participate in trials, and especially Latinos and
Black identifying individuals,
they assume things. "Oh, there's no way this patient can even
make it to all these visits." These assumptions drive bias,
and so really part of our
intervention and making the inclusion criteria so
broad was to really help provide
proof of concept
that
community oncology practice sites can actually refer
patients to clinical trials.
Right? They actually can refer patients that identify as Black and
Latino to clinical trials. And you'll see
as we go on that we are demonstrating proof of
concept.
Attitudes toward clinical trials from a stakeholder,
it was important that it was positive at different stakeholder levels.
Challenges to enrolling patients,
patient emotional barriers, logistics.
Providers kept saying logistics were part of the most common
problem of referring patients to clinical trials
and enrolling them to clinical trials.
There was absolute challenges in trial awareness.
We just heard from Susan. And the process
of screening, there was a variability in the process of screening and enrollment
across each site, and each site did it very differently.
So we had these support tools in this trial.
So
what the trial is, is we are not only working with
the providers and the clinical trial staff at each of these
sub-sites across each of these seven NCORP trial
sites,
community oncology practice sites, but what we have are these tools that
have been adapted over and developed over 20 years on my team,
from BMAP, GMAP days. This is our
web-based information around health, improving clinical
trial and research literacy.
This is available. This has been tested across multiple races and
ethnic groups and identities, across multiple areas
across the country through GMAP and BMAP, but also in the libraries,
where there's the most trusted purveyors of information, are
librarians, and the trusted spaces of information, especially
with respect to health. And so these have been tested and
disseminated in libraries. These
tools have things. They use plain language.
There's clinical trial key concepts like
what is a normal control and all these other concepts that are really important
and emphasizes the pro-social aspect of joining the trial.
So getting to the study.
We're at stage two in the actual intervention, where we're
enrolling patients. Now, with these tools, there are two clinical
trial navigators that are
telecommunicating with
patients and trial sites. So there's one based at Northwestern and one based
at MGH Dana-Farber, and they reach
out with each of the
NCORP sites. And then we have stage three, will
be the six-month follow-up for
providers and patients at each of the sites.
And so we've got these dates. So we've started the
intervention, you see on the right half of that
table, in November with the first three sites, Baptist,
Carle, and SCORE, wave one,
and they end November of this year.
And then wave two for Geisinger and Montefiore started in February of this year,
and they end in February of next year.
And wave three, Aurora and Georgia, start next month, and they
end in May of next year.
So a lot of challenges, but again, this is an implementation trial.
And so I would say the IRB was probably the
biggest challenge that delayed us, but we learned a lot, and we
hopefully will take that feedback and all of the processes of
going through what I would call a standard of care trial
to back in, and hopefully, that will help improve other
trials like this in the NCORP and in the
IRB.
And then there was a lot of turnover with staff.
There's been a bandwidth issue. And again, each
sub-site and each site does things differently, and that is
very challenging when you're trying to do a national
study on NCORP. And interestingly, how
do you then
tailor things locally, but then have broad
recommendations and processes that can go
across these sites and translate across these sites?
And that's what we're learning now, and hopefully we'll be able to
feed back into these sites and to feed back nationally across
NCORP.And we, again, had to be
very
involved and have lots of weekly touch point
meetings with each of the NCORP sites to deepen our
understanding, deepen trust with the site.
And to really
help get to the nitty-gritty of how referral to clinical trials
works. Because, again, there's multiple aspects of
referral. There's your new patients that come in through the door every
day.
Then there's your existing patients that could be
eligible for a new trial that's open at any time.
And then as the new patients come in, they may be eligible for
trials later on. So what our trial is trying to do is prep
not only the clinic to be poised to refer
everybody
to clinical trials or to keep an open mind that everybody should be
referred to clinical trials, but it's to prime the patients that are already
in existence in those community oncology practices and the new patients that are
going to learn about clinical trials.
People these days, and I do a lot of community engaged research,
should not have to sit and suffer in their household or
in their communities and think that, okay, they
have cancer and that's a fatal diagnosis.
But they do, and it's this distrust,
it's generations of distrust, generations of experience
of them and their families with the abuses of medical
system and research
across the country. And so they think that that's a death
sentence if they get cancer, but that's not the case.
And this meeting just proves it, right?
Across all of these days, it proves it.
So, again, trying to change mindsets, both of the
providers and the clinical trial research staff in each of these sites
and of the patients
themselves and the community themselves,
and that's multilevel.
Okay, so we've had lots
of successes, but I would say the most important success...
So these are old numbers. The most important success that
is
important to report is that we are demonstrating that it's
not hard to
enroll Black and Hispanic patients onto clinical trials.
Onto our clinical trial, we now have 48
consented in the far right
on Baptist. There was 161 from Baptist in the
orange column. It should be 161
with the referral, and then
48 for consented. So that's huge.
193 with Carle with referral and
59 consented.
So we're demonstrating that
we are showing the sites, the NCORP sites,
that it's not hard to
refer and then consent, accrue,
Black and Hispanic patients onto these trials.
And we have 40
from Geisinger referred and 24
consented, and 19 from Montefiore and
nine consented. And of course, Wave 3 starts next month.
But these numbers, this rate of
referral and accrual are going up as we
had more and more touchpoints with each of the
sites to work out that implementation, the processes.
And now it's just, "Oh, this is easy."
So I think that's a really important point to make. All right.
Communication, communication, communication.
It can be done and be willing to iterate. Thanks.
So Melissa asked for communication three times, so
that's what you're going to get.
My name's Janice Krueger. I was at the University of Florida when this
project began, which is why it's listed that way
in your program, but I am now at Mayo Clinic in Florida, and I'm
presenting on behalf of my MPI, and myself, Olveen
Carrasquillo. And I'm so thankful to the Edge Lab,
who has helped work with me to support this grant, and I especially want to call
out Dr. Kauer, one of my post-docs, whose
leadership has been
instrumental in the accomplishment of this grant.
So I don't have time to talk about the communication frameworks that really
underline this research. But at the 10,000 foot level, I like to
think of the ME Alex project as advancing our capacity for
translational communication and changing the conversation about clinical trials.
When this particular RFA first came out, I was
thinking about, "Ooh." I was really excited. How would I respond to it?
And one of my colleagues and I were talking about
a young mother who was living in a very rural part of Florida
who had a terminal diagnosis. Her local
hospital had convinced her that she should undergo standard treatment
anyway, just to see if it would work.
They sought a second opinion at the University of Florida, and there happened to be
an IIT that seemed really promising for this particular
case. However,
the spouse of the woman declined the trial because
he felt that standard treatment just sounded safer and less
risky than a clinical trial.
And that particular case really broke our hearts,
because there was a chance to save this young woman, but we didn't have the right
words. And soIn my
world, a lot of people will say, "Well, you can't dumb down the
science." I don't think about it as dumbing it down.
My goal every day is to open up conversations so that we
can really address what the community needs
and respond in an agile way.
So how do we respond in an agile manner to community needs?
We're in a day and age where significant resources go into tailoring
individual treatments to biomarkers, but we invest very
little into tailoring the communication environment in ways that we all know
engender behavioral change.
So this line of research that we're working on is really trying to figure out, in
the clinical trials context, how do we get the right message to the right
person at the right place at the right time to have these important
conversations?
So I'd like you to all go in the way back machine with me for
about 20 years and focus on that blue text.
Inspired by the work of Dr. Pasquet, who was a real pioneer in
thinking about rurality and clinical trials access, I decided to
write my dissertation on what are the communication
needs in this space.
Now, I've since spent my career trying to think about how do we mitigate
these gaps as it relates to communication.
But it really was advances in technology like artificial
intelligence that I think really poise us
to address some of the key needs. So for example,
when do people start thinking about clinical trials?
It's at midnight when you're outside the doctor's office,
you're faced with a cancer diagnosis, or your loved one is, and
you're googling, "What do we do?" Right?
In the last five years, both of my parents were diagnosed with cancer, and I live
1,000 miles away. And so I was that person who
was on the internet at midnight trying to figure out how can I support them?
How do I find trials at Geisinger that they were eligible for
because the doctor said that they didn't have any.
So we'll talk about that later with NCOR.
When you work in an environment that shifts really rapidly, like artificial
intelligence, it's really important to keep community voice and perspective at the
center of the work. And so I am so grateful for our community advisory board,
who meets with us on a very regular basis to review the
ideas and help give us guidance. Of course, we do formative
research collection on a broader scale, but really it's the community advisory
board that helps us sift through what is most important to attend to at any given
point.
As I mentioned, the technology changes really rapidly.
On the far side of your screen, you'll see where this work began in 2017.
And you might be a little
aghast, and that's fine. But that was the cutting edge
technology that we created with a full-time computer
scientist.
And then you look on the other side of the screen, and you see
photorealistic AI representations of real humans,
one of which is me,
that we can create very quickly in a matter of a few minutes.
So how can we leverage that for intervention design?
One of the things I've learned from my computer science colleagues is to always
think about where does your technology add value and to whom?
And
this work started in the colorectal cancer screening space, and one of the things
we quickly realized is the people who benefited the most or liked it the
most were people who didn't have a provider who looked like
them or spoke like them.
And the reason was
because in real life scenarios, they often felt like their demographic
characteristics might influence the quality of the communication
or the treatment that they received, and they liked the aspect that AI was
going to treat them the same as everyone else no matter what.
And so we began to wonder if this could be a way that we could leverage this for
the clinical trial space. So we have this kind of laid out in a
longitudinal way, but please know we're using agile development processes, so
a lot of these things are really feedback loops.
So we started with this idea of virtual humans.
While we were working on the grant, the opportunity to
create photorealistic virtual humans opened up.
We found out from our focus groups that people in the clinical trial space really
liked the idea of talking to real people.
That was an important credibility feature.
We worked with our technical team to create our prototype.
Our advisory board kept giving us ongoing feedback.
We conducted many think-aloud interviews and focus groups
to really evaluate how to enhance usability.
We did key informant interviews, and we're now in the recruitment stage,
and I'll show you a little bit about that.
So as we went through the formative stage of development,
some of the areas of success were people liked the content.
They thought it was clear. They called it comprehensive.
I'm going to tell you that our individual videos were two minutes each, so we
are really living in the Instagram age.
So
thinking that people are going to spend 20 or 30 minutes is kind of out the
window. They thought it was easy to understand, which I'm glad.
I'm a communication scholar, so that was good.
They liked the design. They thought it was engaging, approachable,
user-friendly.
Just a couple of comments. For example, in the middle, one of our
participants said, "I have someone, the virtual community health educator,
who not only represents me or my culture or my background, but somebody
who will walk me through the process."
Especially something that can be a little intimidating, like thinking
about clinical research.
But it wasn't all sunshine and roses.
They gave us some really essential feedback that helped us improve.
One thing that we've learned in this digital space is that while they liked
the representation of a real humanAt the time, we
were using AI-generated voices, and they knew it.
It lacked warmth, it lacked empathy, it didn't match the
person. Those were the kinds of comments we were getting.
So we invested in making sure that we could get voice clones
of the actual virtual humans so they could hear and see that real
person, especially if they engage with them in real life.
We also put their hometowns and what populations that those
individuals specialized in.
We
made adaptations to the videos. We adapted the
usability of the format. The one thing that they really asked for, though,
was also a chat. They wanted to be able to ask questions about trials and
get answers. At the time, we weren't able to do that, but we're just about to
launch that feature as part of the trial. We were able to figure that out.
So an important strategy for precision
messaging, like we've talked about, is making sure that a person gets the
information from the right source.
So research and social influence clearly maps out the different
source characteristics that really drive our perceptions
of that source.
In the past, that was something we could not change.
We were all human, bound by time and space.
But now, our virtual community health educators are not.
So let me give you a little taste of what
the intervention looks like to the user.
I'm Sol, and I live in Jacksonville, Florida. Welcome to the Alex Portal.
Alex will help you learn more about research and help you find any
studies that you might be a good fit for.
I'm meeting with you today because your healthcare team wanted me to provide some
important information about participating in a research study.
Did you know that there are thousands of research studies looking for new
participants at any given time? We, the members of the research
team, pride ourselves on giving patients the opportunity about whether to
participate in research studies.
Many of our patients have not participated in research before, and it's normal to
have lots of questions. My job is to help explain the purpose of
research studies, help you find a research study that might be a good fit for
you, and provide some questions that you might want to ask before you
participate.
Okay, so there's two parts, right? There's the educational piece.
If people haven't heard about clinical trials or cancer research, we
help them with that. But then you heard it'll help you find studies and
refer to them. So that's the second-
I'm Sol, and I live in-
Oh, sorry. Second piece of the intervention.
How many of you have gone to clinicaltrials.gov before?
And how many of you love it?
Okay. We have a few. Great. It's full of great information, but it's
not always user-friendly. It prioritizes studies that are closed or
haven't yet opened. And for some of us, it can be really hard to
understand. And so what we did is took a machine learning
approach
and trained an LLM to translate all of the
studies that are available on clinicaltrials.gov,
driven by an emphasis on plain language and sixth-grade
literacy, but also through communication research on
what are the best ways to talk about research.
So it's not just a low literacy approach.
It's also very customized to improving
communication.
As my colleagues have mentioned, this is a multilevel
intervention. The patient and caregiver referral
networks are very similar. So when people find a study, they can
search and find a study. If they find one that they're interested in,
there's an Email Research Coordinator button.
So we draw out the information from clinicaltrials.gov, we pre-populate
that email, and they're able to connect with a research coordinator.
That works that way for our patient and caregiver portal.
For the healthcare professional, they're able to see what patients see,
but we've also tried to adapt it for our community
oncology clinics, who often don't know what trials are being offered
at Mayo or Moffitt or Miami.
We have multiple, about 12,
virtual community health educators.
Each of these represent three others, so that gives you a
sense of our total enrollment so far is over
1,500, and really how those fall out with our
populations. And then just in closing, our lesson
learned, building in flexibility.
Technology changes can be quick.
Working with the folks with our
AI group, it's constantly learning, especially in the area
of security,
making sure that we don't overburden participants with
security. But also because they're connecting directly with research coordinators,
there does have to be a level so that our research coordinators don't get inundated
with false requests.
And pivoting to address community and clinic needs.
For example, our research coordinators, we weren't originally
giving phone information for participants, and they said, "Please have them put the
phone number. I just want to call them.
I don't want to email them." So we were able to pivot to meet those needs.
Okay. Well, thank you so much for your time, and we look forward to your questions.
Okay. It is right here. Okay, thanks.
You have heard from our wonderful CP2CT
network U01 sites. They are really doing wonderful
multilevel interventions. So the idea then is how do we
coordinate this, not only with the
coordination, but how do you get all what
they are doing out to the research community as well as to the community as well?
And this is where we come in, which is the
DECC. We call ourselves the DECC community.
And what I'm going to present is how do you bridge the gap and then
focus on cross-site level in CP2CT through a
learning collaborative, data coordination, and evaluation.
That's the way to do it. I do not have any
disclosure, but-I think this has been spelt out very well, and I want to
just sort of
repeat the fact that low participation in cancer clinical trials
limits generalizability. So why are we so hung gone that is
so important for us to participate in clinical trials?
We all have different genetic makeup, so everybody needs to be on there to be
able to participate. There are barriers that have been clearly and
succinctly
discussed, and there are limited coordinated scalable
solutions. So this is where the network is so
great, the CP2CT networking. How do we coordinate?
How do we scale the solutions for those of you who are in here and are thinking
about in what way can you really adapt this within your practice as well?
And so there's a need for everything to be integrated and have
multi-site approaches.
So CP2C overview, just to kind of just
set this again. This is an NCI-funded initiative to increase clinical trial
participation. As you have heard, all the implementation are at
different multi-level outreach and educational sites across the United
States. And the focus, as has been said by each person, is really
on referral pathways and accrual to connect populations to
clinical trials, and you can see the figure that brings everybody together.
This is the outstanding team. You see Dr. Larra Marco right there. Wave your hand.
If they have questions, they can come to you.
But the most important person in that group is sitting right there.
So if you need to know anybody, it's Laura.
She makes everything worthwhile and coordinates everything in such a
perfect way. But we do have another MPI, Dr.
Robert Fremont, who is not here. We have an outstanding
community representative in Dr.
Ivan Robinson, and also we have other members of the team as well as
consultants as well.
So what is the role of the DEC? When you have so many
multiple sites who are doing absolutely wonderful work,
what do we come in? The reason that we come in is because it is
very important to centralize data evaluation and then
coordinate all the activities that is going on.
It provides shared infrastructure, governance, and evaluation
systems across all the sites that we have.
It integrates independently operating site into a very unified
network. You have had different interventions that is taking place, different
sites, different institutions,
different use of AI, and different use or even
general ways of doing interventions.
So we have to have a way that we are able to have a unified network that can get
the best practices out to everyone.
It also supports collaboration, dissemination, and alignment within the
NCI goals as well, and we do have a wonderful NCI PD
sitting in front,
that they are always telling us about the importance of this coordination as well
as ensuring that we are acting as one.
So despite the fact that our sites are multiple
institutions, the network is one institution that is focused
on the ultimate goal. So we have four aims in the coordinating
center, and our aims are to establish effective and efficient
administrative process and infrastructure, facilitate all the data
coordination that needs to be done, and management for rapid dissemination,
program evaluation, engagement, and consensus.
That's really a big thing. How do you take everything that is going on in all the
sites and make sure that the evaluation is really consistent and is
being done standardized? And therefore, start a learning collaborative
as well. So I'm going to go aim by aim and
tell you about the activities that we are conducting as well as some of the
outcomes that we have
from this strategy. So the approach to the network
coordination really is centered on structured
governance. There is the steering committee that is comprised
of MPIs of the U01 site, comprised of NCI
program directors, as well as the MPIs of the coordinating
center. They serve as a steering committee that has an oversight of all the
activities that is going on. In addition, one of the things that the DEC
also formed was that we have three working
groups that really runs across majority of the activities that needs to
be done, the data working group, the program evaluation working group, the learning
collaborative. We have regular steering committee and,
thanks. We have program manager meetings, so they are able to do their meeting and
work out the nitty-gritty of what is being done at each of the sites.
We have centralized documentation and knowledge management teams.
We have regular communication channels for alignment and problem-solving, and
it's so great to see everybody emailing at odd hours of the day.
We don't know where everybody is, sometimes traveling, but we're still emailing
each other, we're still coordinating,
in addition to the meeting. And then we have integrated collaboration across sites
and the NCI stakeholders as well. The administrative achievement
from aim one is that I think everybody in this network
will be proud to say that we actually have established a
sustainable national infrastructure for the CP2C network,
which has really streamlined a lot of the administrative
processes that we have. We have been able to create and deploy
centralized reporting platforms that deliver consistent,
actionable insight across the sites, design, coordinates, and
execute high-impact annual meetings,
both in person and sometimes virtual.
And we have deepened the integrations of community members into our activities as
well.The second aim focuses on data coordination and
management, data collection and management.
And this is where the nitty-gritty and really the
impact of the network comes in because there is a lot of data that is being
built. So how do we coordinate? How do we harmonize?
This is the working group that does that.
So we already have a centralized REDCap platform for standardized
data submission. That's the first thing that we needed to do.
There has to be a way that we pull everything in. And I'm looking at the clock.
Did somebody do something to that clock? It's going way fast.
We have developed common data elements aligned with
NCI standards. And then we have the DTAs, the Data Transfer
Agreement. It has all been signed, for secure compliant data
exchange, and we have support harmonized reporting across diverse study
system. And then we have the strategy aligned and construct with site-level
data. I've already mentioned the achievement from talking
about all the activities.
So this is really great. Another one that I would like to highlight is the
partnership with the NCI Metadata and the
CBITT so that we can formalize the CDEs
and plan repository integration, laying the
groundwork for national data harmonization,
interoperability, and long-term scientific value.
So this is really great because the CP2CT network is not only
looking at what is being done, but also looking at how do we
involve all the other research community as well.
The
top one is program evaluation, engagement, and consensus.
I actually see this as one of the really impact and what is going to
be coming out that you can embrace as a research community and also use.
We have been able to develop a logic model that talks about
what input activities and outcomes, whether they are short-term, mid-level, or
long-term outcomes that you really can use when you're looking at multilevel
interventional program. We have developed standardized metrics and
measures across sites. It took Jesus Christ to help us do that, but
we got it done. And we are very proud of that, and we're going to be
putting that out for other
researchers to be able to use this.
We have process evaluations, so we are consistently evaluating ourselves as
a network site to be able to foster continuous improvement.
And we have centralized oversight that really ensures rigor and
comparability and identifying best practices.
This is just a highlight of the program evaluation
achievement that we have. So for example, the program evaluation operational manual
that is developed by the network could be something that anybody could actually
take and use to look at what are some of the program evaluation that needs to be
done in this particular area, what
should the logic model look like. We have
driven consensus on key construct definition,
benchmark metrics, and measures that can also be adapted.
And we have several program evaluation planning tools as well.
For the learning collaborative, the idea for the learning collaborative
is to facilitate communication and collaboration across the CP2C
site. This is really very significant and very important because we
have multiple sites working in Unicum, so we really need to have this
communication and collaboration working.
We work with stakeholders to develop resources and training materials to
address challenges and gaps identified across the network, and
then disseminate the science outcomes to the scientific community,
such as what we are doing right now,
and also in form of peer review publications and within communities that are
adversely affected by health disparities.
So we have a CP2C website. We have a CP2C
speaker series. I hope you all will be able to join our speaker series.
We actually have outstanding speakers that are talking in this
area in addition to our internal speakers as well.
We have advanced authorship, transparency, and collaboration for the learning
collaboratives. So in conclusion, what have we been able to do
within the DEC, working very closely with the U01 size?
Number one key thing is the scalability and sustainability.
We have standardized tools and frameworks that are
reusable across the networks and can be used by anyone actually who
is doing work in this particular area.
We have REDCap and CDE support scalable data system
alignment with the national NCI data infrastructure model
designed for expansion beyond current sites.
There are key takeaways that I actually want to emphasize.
The DEC, what the coordinating center does is enable
integration of independent trials into a cohesive network.
So this is really very key and some of the things that everybody that you
see on this
panel, alongside with our NCI program director, we really worked very hard
on in our first one year to be able to make sure that we are a very
cohesive network. We have learning collaborative that actually
accelerates cross-site innovation.
So you can see there's a lot of innovation going on, and there is
actually an opportunity to learn from each other.
There's data coordination and evaluation that really ensure there's
rigor and there's comparability, and the CP2CT provides a
scalable model to improve equitable clinical trial
access. Value added by DEC shared
infrastructure enables cross-site alignment, harmonized
metrics allow meaningful comparisons, accelerated
dissemination through coordinated platforms, collective innovation
beyond individual site capabilities.
Actually, the whole is really bigger than the sum of all the parts that
you see on this platform. And there's a dissemination and impact as well.
Publications, abstracts, presentation, we are here.
We presented in other conferences before.
We have a speaker series and community engagement initiatives, community
advisory board integrates patient perspectives, and expand
visibility and impact of CP2C strategies. Thank you.
Acknowledging the National Cancer Institute for the grant, as well as
Mayo Clinic Comprehensive Cancer Center for additional leverage funding to be able
to support this work. Thank you.
All right. We have about 20 minutes for questions,
comments, if anybody wants to come to the microphone and
ask a question. So I'll start off for each of our
panelists to answer a question, which is,
now we're
four years into this.
Hindsight is 2020. So what would you have done differently?
So Susan, you want to start?
That's the appropriate place to start.
That's a great question. I think
there's not a whole lot I would have done differently because we
had that first year to really have true
stakeholder engagement. And I remind myself that there are
parts that I wish the outcomes may have gone a different way,
but that's the whole point of doing a study.
So something like our TrialConnect portal that you intuitively think,
like, "Why would that not work?" That's why we
sometimes have to do studies like this, is to figure out and deconstruct
a little bit. So,
I can't think of anything, but maybe others will inspire me to
remember what I forgot.
Melissa, what would you do differently?
I would've learned more about how complex it is to get through the
DCP, the IRB at NCI.
Remarkably challenging, and especially trying to
figure out how best to prep the audience, the people who
serve on the IRB for a,
what I would call a standard of care trial.
This was not a therapeutic trial and was being treated as a therapeutic trial to
try to get through IRB. It took almost two years.
That's
way too long.
Janice?
Yeah, I guess we've all learned a little bit about IRB in this
process.
Like Susan, I can't think specifically about
back then, except for a key thing that's changed is
how much my own knowledge of the work has been enriched by working in this
network.
Yeah.
And our different multilevel interventions intersect in
different ways. And so thinking forward, if I had to do it
again, what I'd be excited about is working with this group of
humans to say, "All right. Let's take these lessons learned and these lessons
learned, and build a better ship."
Okay. Wachi?
Yeah. Same here. I have to say that going in, when we
were applying for the grant, we knew that the center that was
doing it is a great center to work with, so I didn't have any qualms about that.
But if I were to have a magic wand and pick the people who will be part of the
U01 site, these are going to be the people that will be picked because of the
innovation. I think I'm going to go with the IRB also, because
when you have to standardize
the measures and standardize everything, then you still need to go back,
and have an amendment, and I
wish there was a process within IRB that allows...
But we all have different institutions, so
if there was something that IRB could help us
build when you are working within a network rather than your
independent study, I think that would be great.
Yeah. I will have to add IRB too, because the reason I
couldn't show you actual data from the clinics is the IRB said,
"You can't do that." Which I don't understand, with
our approved IRB protocol, why I can't get
actual screening data from the clinics.
By screening, I mean, those four points for each clinic and show it to you
all in real life. Yeah. I don't understand.
So I think the IRB has been a hindrance.
Okay. I don't see anybody up at the mic, so I have that-- Oh, good.
Thank you.
There's somebody.
You saved them for my next question.
Yeah.
Thank you, Shanita.
Hello, everybody. I'm Shanita Zigler-Johnson, Fox Chase Cancer Center.
Thank you so much. I learned a lot from each one of you,
but I have a lingering question just about how
we
push culture change among our physicians when we
really need them to be the ones to initiate these trials,
number one, and then referring clinicians to be
engaged. How do you do that? What are the successful
strategies that you are finding out about?
Yeah. I emphasized in my talk, and I can't
overemphasize it, and this just hit me
recently, after all these years now of doing this.
By broadening our inclusion criteria,
and
doing what we're doing, that's fairly
simple
intervention.
We are creating proof of concept
for the people at the sites, the providers that are enrolling patients,
the clinical trial support people, that it's not hard
to refer
patients,
Black and Hispanic, specifically, patients.
And then when you refer them and you consent them, they actually say yes.
A good majority. And we're demonstrating that, and just
making it easy for people to show them that they can do it,
the physicians, the clinical trial research staff, the sites, the NCORP
sites, community oncology practice sites, just showing that they can do
it, and when they actually do
refer, patients say yes. That is
behavior change.
Mm.
So that's actually an intervention in and of itself, not on
top of our navigation and
the tools that we're implementing.
So that's one way
Shunya, I'll add to what Melissa
said. So our
intervention has a component that's based in our center.
So I think that's probably the culture change you're referring to on some
level, right? Is the physicians at the center, and then there's also community
physicians. And the thing that I've learned over the past
few years is
kind of showing up
in the spaces that they are and
embedding this work there. So
rather than sort of, "Okay, we have a
research study and it's doing these things,"
I had to kind of make friends with our AD of clinical science
to say, "Hey, I need your help to get the
clinical trials office to start
prioritizing looking at our trial portfolio."
So we're going to come once a month when your disease specific
groups are reviewing their accrual to trials, and we're going to
show, here's the cancer burden in the catchment area, here's the trial
portfolio. Oh, look, we have an opportunity
to open trials, I'm just making this up, for gastric cancers
that are more prevalent in X, Y, or Z community.
So there was an element of just
being present in spaces that were new to me
and having sort of colleagues who
are in that space becoming your champions, which takes
time and education. It doesn't always feel fair that it's sort of like
on our end, that we're having to get there.
But,
I feel like that has, on some level, produced culture
change at our institution. And then I think,
although I showed the TrialConnect portal and lack of use, we've taken a sneak peek
at our sort of main outcomes data, and we are
seeing some signal in directions that we had hoped.
And so I think even though, for example, people didn't use the
TrialConnect portal, we had embedded it as part of
a CME that was available to
community physicians. And so perhaps it
sensitizes people in a way where maybe they still don't go through the portal,
but helps kind of bring that awareness.
So I think that consistency of showing up in the
spaces where the people we're trying to reach are.
So I want to mention three examples.
So the first is, our intervention is actually audit with
feedback.
Yeah.
And we know audit with feedback is a behavioral strategy that works.
So we're auditing their clinical trial accrual at those four time points and giving
the feedback to the clinicians so they can see how they're doing and what they
need to improve. The second example and the third example focus
on increasing representation in our studies.
So the second is from the Women's Health Initiative.
I think many of you have heard of the Women's Health Initiative, largest study ever
done in post-menopausal women, 160,000 women were
enrolled into three clinical trials in the observational study starting in
1992, '93. When we started
recruiting, we had a pre-specified
accrual target of 20% minority women.
And at that time, that was unheard of, as was recruiting an
entire cohort of women to a clinical trial.
So we looked at our data, and we saw that Black women and
Hispanic women, and
some of our Asian women were being disproportionately
excluded because of the eligibility criteria and the hormone replacement
trial that, for some reason, had a BMI exclusion there
that nobody knew about.
Yeah.
So we changed the eligibility criteria, and we were able to enroll 18%.
Mm.
Never done before in a clinical trial. Never ever done.
The third example is what I want to talk about something we did in the
Alliance for Clinical Trials, like ECOG-ACRIN.
Alliance is a big N Corp research base.
And our chair at the time, Dr. Monica Bertagnolli, set a goal for us
to accrue 20% minorities, racial and ethnic minorities,
to
treatment trials and to prevention trials.
And for the past three or so years or more,
we have been exceeding 20%, both for treatment
and for control. And in fact, every month, I get a running
three-month average of accruals.
And for some months, for the cancer control trials, we're at
50 and 60% racial and ethnic minorities.
So how did we do it? It was a multilevel strategy,
and one of the strategies was that we actually opened
trials that were for certain
patient populations. And we also do it for rural populations and low income
populations. We have two cancer care delivery studies that are only for rural
patients or only for low income patients.
But, one of the trials was the GET SET
study run by Katie Reeder-Hayes and
Stephanie Wheeler, and it was to increase adherence to hormone replacement therapy
in women who had been treated for breast cancer.
They set a pre-protocol specified accrual of
30% Black women to be accrued to the study.
So the endpoint, I believe they got to
26 or 28%, real close. How did they do that?
Well, they stratified their enrollment, and they had cells.
And so they closed the recruitment cells to white
women when they filled those cells.
And that's how they were able to get to that accrual.
Now, we've taken a lot of flak
in doing that,
saying that was not right. Well, I will tell you that the women
who are non-white go to sites that it takes them longer to get
the trials open.So, sometimes it takes three
visits to consent a minority patient on trial.
And by closing those
cells, we
made the playing field even to allow
these women the opportunity to be on trial.
We also have a database that any investigator in Alliance
can go and look at their institution's accrual by
race, ethnicity,
young age, old age, rural, urban,
and they can see how they're doing.
We also pay for translation for all of our patient-facing
materials that NCI doesn't pay for.
Those are some of the strategies. And then we have an annual Ward and
McCaskill-Stevens Symposium to talk about strategies
for enrolling patients. We have all minority
NCORPs, which they are no longer called minority NCORPs,
but we have all of them represented on our committees
to help us. But it came from the top.
And it's the same for accrual to clinical trials.
You have to have a mindset,
at the top, that clinical trials is the best care for our
patients, and therefore, we will do all that we can for our
patients.
So, I hope that was enough information.
A lot.
Thank you. Thank you for asking the question.
Anybody else have a question?
Oh, I got another one.
So is there time left?
Yeah.
There's time. We got 10 minutes.
10 minutes, yeah.
Hi, Melissa.
Hi.
Usually I don't ask questions, but
this panel somehow prompted me to ask question.
Susan, this is the distinguished panel for the clinical trial accrual
process for NCI. My name is Anil Wali.
I'm program director at NCI, and I have had distinct
honor and pleasure working with the entire distinguished panel for the
last two decades. So it goes back to
GMAP, BMAP, and that's how this whole group came into
existence. And my simple question is, we had a
session before this session about the overall clinical
trial participation by cancer centers.
It's only 7%.
It hasn't gone up for the last 20 years.
So, no matter what we do, somehow the overall
percentage is only around that level.
And in previous session, we had Pat LaRusso, who used to be
at Karmanos Cancer Center, Detroit, Michigan, and she had
recently moved to now Yale Cancer Center.
And still, they are saying the same things, even though they have incorporated
a lot of what Dr. Baskett has been doing with patient
navigation program and over the years.
And they're still proposing that patient navigation is a
crucial component.
So, my question come
comment here is that, is there any
plans to write
commentary in a high-impact scientific journal
and reaching out to Dr. Anthony Letai, new NCI Cancer
Center director, with your recommendations as to how
NCI could implement some of the strategies to
improve the accrual process? I'll stop there.
Absolutely.
I'm an associate JAMA editor, but yeah.
We have every intention to disseminate these findings.
I think it's really important.
Yeah. And I wanted to say that the DECC does have a
publication committee. And I think Susan is-
Yes.
Susan and Jennifer co-leads that.
So, I think if you both do not mind, I think
that's a great idea.
I'm going to have you answer the first one.
So, we have four questions, and I'm going to divvy them up with our panel.
So, the first one, I'm going to turn to Susan,
which is, "Do community outreach programs focused on trial education
also shift attitudes towards seeking care in general,
especially in communities where there tends to be mistrust of the medical system?"
Yeah, that's a great question. And
our ability to place community health educators through this
grant, sort of across our catchment area, has really
shown us that although we're going in with the idea of wanting
to educate about clinical trials,
there is this sort of ripple effect where people then want to
know more about care at the center, as well as
prevention, screening, and early detection.
So, that's the beauty of
a project like this. And in terms of sustainability, it would live in our community
outreach office, where you go in with a topic that's
of shared interest or mutual benefit, but it
certainly opens the door to questions
about either care at the center or other places.
And I'll just say a word about making sure when we're
sending our outreach team and our health educators into
community, that they are knowledgeable enough to be able
to answer these natural questions that come
alongside clinical trials.
Okay, the next question is going to go to Melissa,
by the
poser of the question.
Oh, request.
Yes, request. "In some instances, I found bias
when a provider has a Black patient to automatically assume low
SES, low education, et cetera. How is avoidance of
bias being addressed?"
It's a very important question.
Bias is prevalent,
omnipresent. And so being
Trying to look under the hood of the car, like I mentioned in my talk, and look at
the structure. So that's why I'm an implementation health equity
scientist.
Really looking at structure, because structure helps
improve bias. It's not the only thing, right?
Bias is also at the individual level.
And
processes,
though, can help improve
individual bias. It won't always improve, but it can help.
So forcing
this proof of
concept that, yes, it is easy to
refer
Black and Hispanic patients. Just this process
of making this trial very
inclusive
and easy to accrue, it
helps the sites learn how to improve their processes
of making sure they figure out how to approach every single
patient, regardless of the color of their skin or any other
identities,
for potential
enrollment in clinical trials, but also approaching them to
teach them about why clinical trials are so important and that it
is standard of care for everybody.
So that's part of addressing the bias.
There are multiple other things, but that would be the first point.
Mm-hmm.
So the next question is for Janice, requested:
There is a perception that AI learning has not always been favorable to
understanding population differences within the Black community when it comes
to language and cultural,
for example, generational American Blacks versus
first-generation African Americans.
Are those specificities being
considered?
Thank you so much for that question.
So in the ultimate vision for the work, I
think the idea of precision messaging is to be able to address
those differences, right? So when we begin to use heuristics like
age or
demographics for the kinds of information people need or the way they want it
presented, that's really where we start to introduce
systematic bias because we have to make assumptions about how to communicate
with individuals. And so what we're really trying to do is
build ways
that we can adapt to the user.
So for example, what we would love to do in a version
two of this is be able to
allow people to ask certain questions, right, that would help us
understand how to even better present that information
based on generational issues,
experiential issues.
I'll note one interesting finding that when it comes to
trust, and especially among our underrepresented groups, is that
we have found that co-branding our intervention
dramatically increases trust. So we've heard
past things that have happened that are
wrong.
There is a sense that when cancer centers work together, there is a checks and
balances system. And so they really liked this idea of co-branding,
because if they're all together, they're keeping track of each
other.
And so I think that's a really interesting lesson learned when we think
about the systems that are in place to help us compete with one another
may not be in our community's best interest.
Thanks.
Folake, in the last two minutes, would you like to take this last question, which
is: How much does the problem of the general public's
disbelief in science and
misinformation affect accrual to clinical trials?
Yeah. That's a great question, and I will say, just based on
what the network is doing and how the network is
really viewing it, it has a lot to do.
And I happen to be also part of the AACR Trust in Science
Committee, so I kind of wear that hat as well.
But it's
there. We cannot
ignore it. And I think the way the network is really
addressing this is disseminating the science back to the community.
I think oftentimes, we serve as
gatekeepers of our scientific discoveries, and we keep
everything as if it's a secret for the scientists and the
investigators to own, and we only give out what we
feel that the community needs. And I think one of the things that I love
about the network is this idea that, for example, anybody could
attend the webinar that we have. We are looking at ways to really be able to
disseminate the science that is coming out, that we communicate it
openly to everyone, and that is how trust is built.
It's like any other relationship.
If we are open and we communicate, the trust will be there.
But we are still lagging behind. We have a lot to do.
That's perfect. And that was a perfect conclusion to this
session. I'd like to thank our panelists again and thank all of you.